- [Voiceover] Let's think
about the infinite series,
so we're going to go from
n equals one to infinity,
of one over two to the n plus n.
And what I want to do
is see if we can prove
whether this thing converges or diverges.
And as you can imagine based
on the context of where
this video shows up on
Khan Academy that maybe
we will do it using the comparison test.
At any point if you feel
like you can kinda take
this to the finish line, feel free
to pause the video and do so.
So in order to kind of
figure out or get a sense
for this series right over
here, it never hurts to
kind of expand it out a
little bit, so let's do that.
So this would be equal
to when n equals one this
is gonna be one over
two to the one plus one,
so it's gonna be one over two plus
one, it's gonna be one third
plus that's n equals one.
When n equals two it's gonna
be one over two squared,
which is four plus two plus one over six.
Plus let's see we go
to three, n equals one,
n equals two, n equals
three is gonna be one over
two to the third, which
is eight plus three is 11.
So one over 11, maybe
I'll do one more term.
Two the fourth power is going
to be 16 plus four is 20.
Plus one over 20 and obviously we
just keep going on and on and on.
So it looks, it feels like
this thing could converge.
All of our terms are
positive, but they are getting
smaller and smaller quite fast.
And if we really look at
the behavior of the terms
as n gets larger and
larger, we see that the two
to the n in the denominator will grow
much, much faster than the n will.
So this kind of behaves
like one over two to the n,
which is a clue of something that we might
be able to use for the comparison test.
So let me just write that down.
So we have one over, so
the infinite series from
n equals one to infinity
of one over two to the n,
and so when n equals one this is
going to be equal to one half.
When n is equal to two this is
going to be equal to one fourth.
When n is equal to three
this is equal to one eighth.
When n is equal to four this
is equal to one sixteenth.
And we go on and on and on and on.
And what's interesting about
this is we recognize it.
This is a geometric
series, so let me be clear.
This thing right over here,
that is the same thing
as the sum of from n
equals one to infinity of
one half to the n power, just
writing it in a different way.
And since the absolute
value of one half, which
is just one half, so
because the absolute value
of one half is less than one we know that
this geometric series converges,
we know that it converges
And actually we even
have formulas for finding
the exact sum of or to figure
out what it converges to.
And so we know this thing
converges and we see that
actually these two series
combined meet all of the
constraints we need for
the comparison test.
So let's go back to what we
wrote about the comparison test.
So the comparison test,
we have two series, all
of their terms are greater
than or equal to zero.
All of these terms are
greater than or equal to zero.
And then for the corresponding
terms in one series,
all of them are going
to be less than or equal
to the corresponding
terms in the next one.
And so if we look over here,
we can consider this one,
the magenta series, this
is kind of our infinite
series of dealing with A
sub n and that this right
over here is, well I
already did it in blue
this is kind of the blue series.
And notice all their
terms are nonnegative and
the corresponding terms
one half is greater than
one third, one fourth is
greater than one sixth,
one eighth is greater than one eleventh.
One over two to the n is
always going to be greater
than one over two to the n plus n for
the n that we care about here.
And since we know that
this converges, since we
know that the larger one converges.
It's a geometric series
where the common ratio
the absolute value of
the common ratio is less
than one, since we know
that the larger series
converges therefore, the
smaller series or the
one where every corresponding
term is less than
the one in the blue one,
that one must also converge.
So by the comparison test the series
in question must also converge.